all right tanisha
tanisha where are you from originally
where did you grow up um san fernando
valley
san fernando valley um my dad's from
compton
um my dad was um a heroin
and a red devil and sharon
vcp um by the time i got
born i was three years old and
my dad was abusive to my mother
and had a lot of women and
he was abusive to them too um he got
killed
i have a brother and sister or sister
out there
that i never seen or heard from
since i've been they've been born and um
my dad got killed by her
the baby's grandfather um
performing on the property um
it's hard for me to um to let my father
go
um that's why i want to leave california
my father took me from my mother
at the age of six when he got killed
i've been with my grandmother ever since
i've never got to talk to my mother
she's a pastor she lives in louisiana i
never met her
since i was born
it was something that they took from my
family took from me
and i feel it was selfish and it made me
um suicidal
because i love my mother and even though
i didn't know what happened
i always wanted my mother was something
that
i didn't want nothing to confront i'm
i'm it's hard for me to have things
taken from me or to lose things um
that i love so much um
you struggle with depression i struggle
with depression
and suicidal and voices
i have anxiety bad now i have cancer now
i have breast cancer i'm in pain all the
time
i've been struggling with cocaine crack
cocaine
since i was 15 my cousin introduced me
to it
i never knew what it was um
i leaned on that before my depression so
i won't feel anything
um until i've met a guy this
recently that may turn my life around
i left track alone so i wouldn't lose
him
because i left lost everything in my
life and my relationships
before him i lost everything you know
constantly
my kids i have six kids because of crack
yes
i have six kids and the only reason i
lost my kid
because my family went behind my back
and i just said i wasn't around
it wasn't for it wasn't for drugs i was
living at um job court
when i was young where do you live today
i live on the street right now i lost my
house um
like a year ago i have section 8 um
because of my breast cancer and um
you're going to attend
yeah i'm in a tent now it's hard i cry
every day
because my relationship is going sour
and it made me go back into depression
and now i turn to crystal and i don't
like it and i don't want to be on it
but it helps me to try to maintain
but it's worse because i know these
guys do not get on crystal it's a
handmade drug and um
it's with chemicals every young kids are
listening
um i hear a lot of voices and screams
and um ghosts and everything
but um i was born with a gift that i
could see things before it happened
anyway
but it's even scarier when you can um
run the crystal with the crystal
the crystal make you sick it's hard for
me to kick it more than
the crap i could crack on my own not a
drug program
this cold turkey and i've been dealing
with that for years so
a crystal is harder i get sick
i get weak i get nauseated and i can't
let it go
because i get sick too sick
so i'm trying to find a detox now or
some help
to kick that um whatever you do
don't turn to get off drugs as soon as
possible
because there's a lot of people out here
with hiv and
they don't care where i live right now
and that's called the bottoms
and they doing sex with women and men
and it's scary because i woke up
when my parents halfway down they put
memorial in my
bristol and um i'm scared
um i was caring for my boyfriend i'm
scared for me
and um it's a struggle out here on the
streets
it's hard and
i'm depressed every day because of the
corona is out and
it's hard to get things done faster
um i wish nothing i wish no drug on
anyone
our community is full of stds and
and drugs and it's the worst
is downtown l.a
i've never seen nothing like this street
i'm on 17th and
close to washington it's like i'm in a
devil
pit already in hell because they do so
much
wrong over there and so much evil i pray
every day and i pray my church music
and i keep my bible open and i'm just
depressed
and sad i feel so much people's pain
and the evil and it's scary
but i just want to say god be with me
god be with you and i hope the next
generation make it
because kids are getting messy and
everything out right on that
um and the police corrupt
you know everywhere um
i just hope you find that boy that
whatever
that's blocking you and when you came up
as a child
finding god because that's the only way
to go
and i realized that because i keep
letting his hand go and
god's a selfish guy so just hold on to
his holy
his holy end and pray for me too
thank you do you feel like the childhood
that you had
kind of made my life like it is yes yes
i do
um i blame my grandmother i think if
things were different your childhood you
might have
well i you know what i wish i tried so
hard
to keep my kids from feeling what i went
through
but it's like my oldest child have
depression
and the same and suicidal just like me
but the rest of them are strong
but um you know they don't have me they
don't have me
and that's what that's what they laugh
now and if that and if my kids are
watching
i love you i don't love you no one more
than the other
because i know that mahogany thinks that
i don't love her because i don't call
her
i don't call you the one of you guys i
want you guys to live your life i don't
want to be a stumbling block
or make promises or
anything like cuz i never did and i just
want to keep that
and you keep that in mind that i'm here
for you
and the spirit and i love you and i'm
sorry
that wasn't there and i was strong
enough
to go to court and try to get my first
child back but it hindered me
and it made me fall back to depression
more
were you able to raise your kids no i
wanted to because i didn't want them to
go through what i went through
but without a mother that's showing that
i wanted
to to
you know save them from the world you
know of
destruction you know like it is you know
i mean
i wanted to protect them from the pain
that i feel today
but i couldn't i couldn't you know
um i didn't know how have you ever been
anything for your depression at all
yes i have um i take excitement
and they work to a certain step you know
um when i get miss a day or two and like
and you can't do that
you have to stay constantly on your
medication
and by the corona being out it was hard
for me to get medication
um it's just like god i'll let god's
hand go i let the meds go you know and
you know because the pain is crucial
that i have
i have several knots and there is a
tennis ball
and i can barely do anything i can
really have three pounds
with my elbow one elbow i have
bad knees my i'm in pain all the time i
can't get out of bed
my bladder is where i can't feel
i gotta pee um i'm losing
you know um appetite constantly
because of my anxiety and my depression
together and mommy with him my cousin
recently and my baby dad within a year i
lost every
four people and um that that was busy
you know but i'm still praying i'm
holding on
but sometimes i feel like i want to hurt
somebody the people that's hurting other
people
you know that they don't deserve it
anybody feeling like that and i'd be
trying trying so hard
nothing just to act on it you know
and call for help and i would have my
boyfriend no more
he was my best friend before i he was my
boyfriend
i wouldn't be with him until i had to
figure it out as he met with me
you've been on the street for how many
years yes
how many years well we um i've been on
streets for a long time all my life
rather really um my kids was all raised
in one house
with my auntie and she was abusive
to certain kids of them like one or two
and uh one of them got took it from her
and
uh one of my kids got molested before
she died
by her husband and uh i'm fighting with
that too
you know because i know what my daughter
went through
um i had made my left hand when i was
young
also um i got raped
for something i didn't do i could have
stole some
crack cocaine for some dope dealer and
they gave rape me
and beat me with guns um i landed my own
puddle of blood
for my boyfriend for five dudes and
i try to kill myself at 12 and i'll be
feeling like that lately
sometimes i feel that up
i wasn't meant to be here for to be
happy
you know
i don't wanna i don't wanna leave my
kids on this earth
i wish i never had kids because i don't
mean like
i don't love them but this world is real
bad
and uh it's feel like i'm in hell
already
um every day i fight i'm fighting the
battle
to stay alive because of the coroner
because i can get it and i can die and
sleep
with the cancer so i had to stay inside
my den every day
24 hours and knees almost
what was the best time of your life um
having my baby come
out my kids i was it
and my boyfriend i knew what i have but
now it went bad
because where we at it's like the devil
fit like i said and it's like i don't
over help me anymore
but it's always that little bit of smile
come out of him
that reminds me who he really is so i
hold on tight
because i don't want to leave him there
and i got something telling me this
just to hold on but i can't because he's
having sex with every
female it is and i don't want him to
fall into a trap with everybody else be
lost out here
and what's what's the most important
lesson you've learned
from being on the street all these years
nothing at god's handle because
without him there's nothing possible
okay
nothing capable of happening without his
blessings
because god himself is god you know i
know a lot of people don't believe in
god but
it's always a chance you know
to change it's good change is good
it's always worth to try never give up
you know you know it's piece of failure
you know i just say
always give yourself a chance you know
um everybody's not bad
you know you have the good and you have
the bad you have to go through life
to find out certain things i don't take
the risk
you know that's that life is
like i said life wait for no one and
when you're on drugs you don't exist
all right well thank you thank you thank
you
good luck with everything
you